the Joe Rogan experience that's my hope
for the future is that games are like
that and you're actually gonna be able
to exercise doing that because I think
that if you had a game where you're in a
warehouse and you're actually running
for your life again you know and demons
are chasing you and shooting down things
like your heart rate would be jacked you
could do that for an hour and get a sick
workout in and have an amazing good time
that would be awesome you can get in
great shape running from demons you
would I wouldn't have to get up so early
in the [ __ ] morning
think about this game if you could play
this game but you could play this game
in a warehouse where you know you have
all of the boxes and all those stairs
they're all real stairs in real boxes
yeah yeah you're running around this
pre-designed map and you're actually
engaging with these VR demons with a
haptic feedback so [ __ ] glory killing
them and their parts they really into
this glory killing but the really
problem with is calling it glory killing
is it sounds too much like glory hole
does inside right Jamie they have a new
ride that got announced today for I
guess out here at Disneyland the new
Marvel Comics Avengers campus is gonna
be opening up in the summer they have a
disk or a spider-man ride where it
sounds like you put on a 3d a headset I
think just goggles in somehow they're
tracking your hands so during the ride
you shoot things for points oh and then
there's no spider web and there's a
leader bed sauce inside the ride for
like weekly daily and monthly stuff the
the the level of sophistication going on
with the games whether your mouse and
keyboard or controller though it would
be hard to achieve in VR I think VR
offers like a very specific unique and
[ __ ] amazing experience and I would I
would just like separate the two like
you know when when when when we're
making VR games we're definitely trying
to do something else
which is cool and of itself and in and
of itself but there's like not only just
in our game but in a lot of games like
there's
resource management there's like
high-level skill Metta [ __ ] happening I
mean you know you play [ __ ] quake so
like you know that that's hard to
reproduce in VR in certain ways at least
at this time but but I think that's the
thing like they want it happens a lot in
games where people want to take how you
feel or how a movie engages you and
apply it to a game and I think it's like
let a game be its own it let it game be
a game let a movie be a movie let VR or
be its own [ __ ] experience like that
looks [ __ ] awesome like but yeah if
we just yeah so so there's still though
yeah I would love to kill you know Dean
I we have the VR game I should just play
it but what I what I'm saying is like if
someone made a doom warehouse will you
guys take a fourteen thousand square
foot warehouse just outfit it
specifically for doom you got a line
around the block of Psychopaths waiting
a platter thank you an hour
I mean seriously especially somewhere
like Texas where there's a bunch of
warehouses like you know you know some
warehouse district where you get three
or four of them and set them up for
different maps in the game that'd be
[ __ ] awesome man
I mean they're real close to being able
to do something like that where it would
be really accurate to where you could
have like a laser sight on your rifle
and see things through the goggles and
I'd be [ __ ] badass although it is
it's it's it's lame I what's not lame
you know Carmack can do anything he
wants but he's doing AI now like he's
not doing VR anymore I heard I heard he
was just consulting with oculus but now
he's pursuing AI will this be honest
he's too smart he's from another planet
him any lon muskie get together and
share notes yes yes they're both super
wizards yeah totally he's I mean I'm
sure he feels challenged by AI yeah and
you know he likes a challenge he's a
very interesting guy to talk to you too
I really enjoyed talking to him yeah he
is awesome and you really think about
what he's accomplished in the world of
video games I mean he's the Mac Daddy
amazing yes he's the the guy who started
it all really the if you enjoy 3d games
that's the guy do you guys like keep
your eye open for like where vr is
headed
things like that and go well not yet
we're not ready for that yet but one day
down the road we'll have something like
that kind of a different again like
we're like it's sort of like with cars I
went to school for automotive design
right yeah I would wind up in videogames
uh just because I love videogames you
know the the training in automotive
design art have you ever been Art Center
no it's dude you should [ __ ] go it's
[ __ ] where is it it's in Pasadena and
it's okay it's like the Harvard of
design schools like it's a me and they
do cars there and products but the yeah
the car is that they haven't display you
know the big clay models about that big
they're [ __ ] amazing and and a really
really amazing place you know the the
the design process that you learn there
you can apply to kind of anything
why would you say anything but a lot of
things certainly a videogame for sure
because it's just kind of it's actually
the questions you're asking which is
like how do you start from nothing to
something you know like that involves
large groups of people and you kind of
learn that there I forgot your original
question but oh yeah no it's like you
know so I use a lot of car analogies at
the office quite a bit and and it's kind
of like we make a race car and and if VR
is something else that's like an SUV
that's like just another kind of car so
like we kind of perfected how to make
race cars and it's been doing it since
the 90s so like doom eternal is just
another race card and Laughlin so what
you're saying I'm just thinking that as
augmented reality and then virtual
reality become more and more accessible
to consumers I'm wondering you know like
where video games are headed I'm
wondering if you if you think that's
where they're heading there's always
going to be a place for them on an
actual video game I think on an actual
computer rather I think they'll always
be a place for them in the actual video
game I think the the that's where my
focus is other people like Carmack are
looking to see where well not anymore
but where video games were going to go
next but I am fully focused on where
they are now and how to make what they
are now better
[Applause]